je vois maintenant qu'on revienne sur
l'ensemble de cette opération commencée
il ya huit jours avec l'événement
tragique de cet après midi l'ensemble de
cette opération donc noura nous est
racontée par françoise ou beyrouth à
nouveau dans la guerre
nous sommes le vendredi 12 à prix ont la
deuxième journée consécutive l'armée
israélienne bombarde la banlieue sud de
beyrouth fief du parti chiite
pro-iranien le hezbollah premier mort
premiers blés sous les populations
civiles puis le vacarme des armes vers
le nord du liban
cette offensive israélienne est une
réponse aux attaques du hezbollah qui
depuis plusieurs mois lance ses
roquettes katioucha sur le nord d'israël
faisant plusieurs victimes parmi les
soldats israéliens la ville la plus
importante kiryat shmona et évacuer
cette région la galilée vidé de la
moitié de sa population
là aussi dans ce nord d'israël la guerre
fait des victimes
comme cette femme dont la voiture vient
d'être touché par un tir de la milice
pro iranienne samedi 13 avril alors que
le hezbollah continuent d'harceler le
nord d'israël un hélicoptère de tsahal
tire un missile sur une ambulance d'une
association islamistes près de la ville
de ti vct à bord du véhicule
si le team dont quatre enfants israël
sous ce n'est un combattant du hezbollah
d'être un des passagers de cette voiture
et c'est là toute la difficulté de cette
guerre contre le hezbollah
les combattants pro iraniens sont
partout parmi la population du sud liban
l'opération israélienne les raisins de
la colère s'intensifient les objectifs
civils sont touchés comme cette centrale
électrique à l'est de beyrouth c'est
désormais l'exode parmi les populations
du sud liban ils sont des centaines de
milliers sur les routes dans le nord
d'israël
ceux qui ont choisi de rester se terrent
dans les abris et au moment où la france
et les etats-unis tentent d'obtenir
l'arrêt des combats
au septième jour de guerre nouvelle
escalade ce matin un avion israélien
lâche un missile sur une maison
d'habitation près de la baptiser une
famille de onze personnes dont sept
enfants
ils trouvent la mort et il est 15h cet
après midi en réplique à un tir du
hezbollah l'artillerie israélienne
bombarde un camp de l'onu à cana où
s'étaient réfugiés plus de 600 libanais
lille en 94 morts plus de 120 blessés